now one of the things that is kind of a
double-edged sword if you will is the
financialization of Bitcoin right so
back in 2012 up till it's called
2017-2018 it was pretty much if you were
into Bitcoin it would I don't say anti
Wall Street but definitely had a
different vibe different ethos a
different community than a lot of what
you see in Wall Street and traditional
finance for legacy finance there's been
a blurring of that line over the last
few years some of that is seen as a
positive development right getting more
liquidity into the market kind of more
sophisticated players a lot of the more
significant analysis you get kind of
being the mainstream press more all that
kind of stuff there's also concern
though around the financialization of
Bitcoin leading to a dampened upside
potential because it kind of gets
incorporated into some of those more
legacy markets and asset classes and
funds how do you think about this right
like what are the positives and
negatives and kind of where do you think
that we come out on a net basis that's a
great question I think there's a lot of
anxiety in this space around what
happens when the institutions do come
you know in late 17 we hypothesize that
they would come a little bit earlier and
I do think they will come and I see it
as some sort of an inevitable thing that
will occur it's nothing to be afraid of
I think a lot of people look at this and
there's this anxiety around okay what
happens when Wall Street comes this big
evil Wall Street coming in get a mess
with Bitcoin my little cypherpunk
you know dream and I don't think it's a
bad thing so you know first and foremost
different financial instruments like
futures options and lending and
borrowing are all normal market
activities they enhance price discovery
the enhanced liquidity and they allow
different operators in the crypto space
or in Bitcoin specifically to hedge the
risk so this means that you know
potentially options have the ability to
dampen you know the the downside risk
for miners which is a good thing so
maybe we have a more continuous hash
rate rather than difficulty adjustments
that are lower than
go to your chespin so you know I don't
think it's a bad or a good thing I think
it's a basically a market neutral thing
it's how markets work they essentially
allow the efficient price discovery the
allow Park market participants to hedge
if certain types of risk all of the
different financial instruments that
I've seen come out I think are great for
different operators like I said before I
think a big one that a lot of people
have a sticking point with is lending
and borrowing because people go oh
fractional reserve lending is bad and I
say well how much is bad so yes
fractional reserve banking has led to
what we've seen you know Bank different
Bank issues over many many times over
the last four hundred five hundred years
in terms of all fighting you know
financial recorded data we do see that
after a decade or two we typically have
liked bank runs people go to their bank
the bank has done fractional reserve
banking and their money may or may not
be there fractional reserve banking in
and of itself is not a bad thing the
bank compensates you for that risk by
offering you an interest rate you should
be evaluating the different risks at the
banks in which you deposit your coins I
had ordered a policy your money you
should be evaluating the risks in which
you were being compensated for with that
interest rate banks server could
function in the economy which is to lend
money to individuals who don't have that
money now whether that be your personal
home personal car or business these
aren't bad things loans and bond lending
and borrowing is not a bad function when
we do too much of it it becomes a better
thing and so I think Bitcoin at that
base layer having only 21 million
bitcoins that immutable monetary policy
where it cannot be changed the
settlement and the custodial guarantee
that you have when you hold Bitcoin
yourself that's phenomenal I think that
alone is a huge breakthrough in the
world economy and so yes if you choose
to take on a more risk and give your
coins to different lending companies out
there you're being compensated for that
risk now is 3 5 6 percent enough I don't
know that's a subjective thing but I
don't think it's an inherently bad thing
yeah and I guess this kind of leads into
a
aspect of the financialization is you
get more sophisticated players that come
into the market they have that
experience from various asset classes
and there's a lot of people who say look
these markets are incredibly manipulated
right there's whales out there these
people know what they're doing and
they're able to increase and decrease
price through manipulation how do you
think about that and do you think it's a
fair kind of accusation to say that
those are the sophisticated non Bitcoin
type audience doing that or do you think
it's maybe kind of everyone in the
market yes so the concern over whales
because we're all minnows and dolphins
as some people put it you know we're
worried about these whales splashing
around and causing us to you know
causing these really intense price
gyrations whales have been a concern
since 2012 I remember a lot of the
Bitcoin talk there I think there's a
wall observer is one of the oldest
threads on Bitcoin talk where people
talk about giant bitter haskell walls
where a whale will go put a giant wall
in to kind of scare the market the most
famous one is called the bear whale so
from 2015 I think an individual put in a
30 million dollar cell wall that was
eaten by bitcoiners and it's a famous
date where we slayed the bear whale so
if you google the slaying of the bear
well that's when the bitcoiners all came
together to slay that there whale as
Bitcoin has increased in adoption in
terms of number of hollers liquidity and
liquidity I mean what I mean by that is
the badasses Fred the depth of the order
book and volume as is evolved increased
so you have more market participants and
greater liquidity the ability for a
whale to influence the market is
diminished because there are more market
participants that they have to fight
against which would be I guess what you
could call maybe like a true price a
price minus the influence of one single
participant every market has large
participants you have tech companies
where founders hold 20 30 40 percent of
the company you have different types of
commodities where
certain investment bank or hedge fund
might own a large percentage we cannot
control who owns X percentage of Bitcoin
as the markets become more liquid those
large poplars of Bitcoin will be able to
influence the price less than once